And he thought about it quite a long time,
and finally he said, "Ma'am, I miss almost all of it."
And he's one of the most traumatized people
I've seen from that war.
"Ma'am, I miss almost all of it."
What is he talking about?
He's not a psychopath.
He doesn't miss killing people.
He's not crazy. He doesn't miss getting shot at
and seeing his friends get killed.
What is it that he misses? We have to answer that.
If we're going to stop war, we have to answer that question.
I think what he missed is brotherhood.
He missed, in some ways,
the opposite of killing.
What he missed was connection
to the other men he was with.
Now, brotherhood is different from friendship.
Friendship happens in society, obviously.
The more you like someone,
the more you'd be willing to do for them.
Brotherhood has nothing to do
with how you feel about the other person.
It's a mutual agreement in a group
that you will put the welfare of the group,
you will put the safety of everyone in the group
above your own.
In effect, you're saying,
"I love these other people more than I love myself."
Brendan was a team leader
in command of three men,
and the worst day in Afghanistan —
He was almost killed so many times.
It didn't bother him.
The worst thing that happened to him in Afghanistan
was one of his men was hit in the head with a bullet
in the helmet, knocked him over.
They thought he was dead.
It was in the middle of a huge firefight.
No one could deal with it, and a minute later,
Kyle Steiner sat back up
from the dead, as it were,
because he'd come back to consciousness.
The bullet had just knocked him out.
It glanced off the helmet.
He remembers people saying,
as he was sort of half-conscious,
he remembers people saying,
"Steiner's been hit in the head. Steiner's dead."
And he was thinking, "I'm not dead."
And he sat up.
And Brendan realized after that
that he could not protect his men,
and that was the only time he cried in Afghanistan,
was realizing that.
That's brotherhood.
This wasn't invented recently.
Many of you have probably read "The Iliad."
Achilles surely would have risked his life
or given his life to save his friend Patroclus.
In World War II, there were many stories
of soldiers who were wounded,
were brought to a rear base hospital,
who went AWOL,
crawled out of windows, slipped out doors,
went AWOL, wounded,
to make their way back to the front lines
to rejoin their brothers out there.
So you think about Brendan,
you think about all these soldiers
having an experience like that, a bond like that,
in a small group,
where they loved 20 other people
in some ways more than they loved themselves,
you think about how good that would feel, imagine it,
and they are blessed with that experience for a year,
and then they come home,
and they are just back in society
like the rest of us are,
not knowing who they can count on,
not knowing who loves them, who they can love,
not knowing exactly what anyone they know
would do for them if it came down to it.
That is terrifying.
Compared to that,
war, psychologically, in some ways, is easy,
compared to that kind of alienation.
That's why they miss it,
and that's what we have to understand
and in some ways fix in our society.
Thank you very much.
(Applause)